If you’re in a Final Destination movie,
your best hope of surviving is to look for
the signs.
Right from the opening credits, there are
signs of impending danger, like the scissors
pointed at Kimberly’s head in this photo,
or the blade directed at her face right next
to that.
Kimberly has an eye on her keychain, a clue
that she will be the clairvoyant whose vision
saves the lives of several people, and when
she first wakes up that afternoon, the time
is 1:08, an anagram of 180, referencing the
flight number of the big accident from the
first movie.
There would be many other appearances of the
ominous number 180, as well as many other
signs that often go unnoticed.
To hear about every last secret, stick around
to the end of this video.
This video is sponsored by Hunt a Killer.
[INTRO]
Welcome to Things You Missed and if you’re
watching on upload day, Happy Halloween.
This year’s Halloween may not be what we’re
used to, but hopefully you found a way to
enjoy it.
Final Destination 2 brought in a new director.
James Wong handed it over to David R. Ellis,
who was mostly known for work in the stunt
department -- so the result was… one really
cool spectacle at the beginning of the movie,
but a lot of… weird stuff for the rest of
the film.
“A man with hooks…
I think I see a man with hooks.”
We’ll get into that, but first, let’s
get into the Things You Missed.
"You missed that? Aw!"
Kimberly first wakes up at the beginning of
the movie when she hears a strange voice utter
her name.
“Kimberly.”
I believe this is the voice the coroner, William
Bludworth, who later somehow know her name
when Clear brings her to the morgue to ask
questions about death, suggesting that William
could be much more than a creepy dude who
knows a lot about death.
This is effectively the first sign that she
actually notices about the tragedy that would
become known as the Route 23 pile-up.
The next is when her door suddenly closes.
In the past we’ve seen that Death is often
associated with the wind.
Her an her friends are headed off on a road
trip to Daytona Beach, a parallel to the first
movie, where Flight 180 is also a travel related
accident.
When she drives away, her car is leaking transmission
fluid that almost looks like blood.
In our Flight 180 analogy, the equivalent
of the airport terminal would be the highway
on-ramp, and just as Alex is disturbed by
a creepy missionary, Kimberly is startled
by a creepy old woman collecting trash, which
her friend Dano finds way funnier than it
actually is.
*laughter*
Ok.
They get on the highway and see a school bus
transporting a sports team.
There’s a banner that says Demolish the
Mustangs… smoke their butts -- and later
down the road they would encounter a Ford
Mustang with smoke coming out of the butt,
and it gets demolished in the accident.
We see the bus for realsies after the premonition,
and learn that it’s a bus from Mt. Abraham
High School, which is the school from whose
French class fatally boarded Flight 180.
Alex Browning encountered a couple of references
to hell and demons before boarding that plane,
and when Kimberly changes the radio station,
AC/DC’s “Highway to Hell” starts playing,
which coincidentally I used to sing every
day in 6th grade on my way to English class.
Dano tosses his ILLEGAL SUBSTANCE joint out
the window and it lands on the windshield
of a woman named Kat, where it burns some
leaves that are stuck there.
This could either be a sign of the fiery explosions
caused by the pile-up, or any of the other four
other fiery explosions in the film.
The real scariest part of this movie is just
the fact that like 50% of the people on this
road are driving under the influence.
Between Kat, Rory, and this truck driver,
it’s a wonder that it took five whole minutes
for a major accident to occur.
By the way, the drinking driver represents
a company called Hice Pale Ale, a reference
to stunt co-ordinator Freddie Hice.
You probably didn’t miss the weird kid smashing
together the toy cars.
I mean who does that?
But what you may not have noticed is that
it’s a red truck crashing into a big blue
commercial vehicle, which is not only what
happens at the end of Kimberly’s vision,
but also what happens for real, when Kimberly
loses her friends after stepping out of the
vehicle.
The truck that starts the big pile up in Kimberly’s
vision has a loose wire hanging off of it,
which brings back memories of the end of the
first movie, where a similar wire almost caused
the death of the main characters Clear and
Alex.
This truck also has a familiar license plate
VKY 722.
We last saw this plate in my Things You Missed
episode on Stephen King’s Misery, where
it was the license plate of Paul Sheldon’s
car, and I mentioned it has appeared in many
movies, like The Freshman, Shaft and The Wolf
of Wall Street.
Finally, after the premonition, when the real
accident occurs, Kimberly looks up and sees
a sign that says, “Warning Work Ahead: Next 180 Feet.”
This is the number 180 resurfacing as it has
so many times since Flight 180, as I discussed
when I covered the first movie.
The new number added to the mix this time
is number 23.
In addition to the accident taking place on
Route 23, Kimberly notices that the next service
station is 23 miles away after her Dad calls
to warn about her car’s leak.
Final Destination 2 is pretty much the same
exact movie as the first, with one key difference.
This time William Bludworth tells them that
the only way to defeat death is with new life,
so the majority of the film is spent trying
to make sure nothing bad happens to this woman,
Isabella, so she can safely deliver her baby,
and theoretically force Death to completely
reset its list.
There’s a scene later on where we learn
that each character is connected by the fact
that they should have died at some point over
the last year, but each of them missed their
appointment with death because of one of the
Flight 180 survivors.
At the end, Isabella is revealed not to have
been on Death’s list yet, but that doesn’t
mean she isn’t connected to the others.
We first see her in the premonition driving
her white van, which has a logo for Fresh
and Fast Florist.
In other words, she’s delivering flowers,
and I think the reason she’s there, is because
she’s delivering to the 1 year anniversary
memorial at Mt. Abraham High School that we
hear about on the radio.
“...candlelight vigil to mark the 1 year
anniversary of the crash of Flight 180, will
be held at 8PM tonight at the Mt. Abraham
High School auditorium.”
After the premonition, there’s even a part
where she asks to get through because she
has to make a delivery.
“Excuse me, is there any way that we could
drive around?
I have a delivery--”
“You need to get back into your vehicles.”
I think that fate had her making this delivery
because Death wanted Clear to be lured out
of hiding, and needed her to end up at the
Lakeview Hospital when Eugene’s room exploded.
It’s all part of Death’s design.
But there would be many more accidents before
then, each with clues of their own to uncover.
The holiday we've been waiting for all year
has finally arrived and if you’re like me,
you’ve found something scary to enjoy at
home this year because of COVID-19.
And if you’re like me, you’re looking
to keep things scary all year round.
Something that I’ve been enjoying to fill
that Halloween void is Hunt a Killer’s Blair
Witch game.
It's basically a subscription box that puts
you in the center of a new horror mystery
taking place in the universe of one of the
greatest found-footage movies of all time:
The Blair Witch Project.
Each season consists of 6 episodes.
When you open the box you'll receive your
case file, which consists of realistic evidence,
we're talking journals, police reports, maps
and other documents that will help you solve
the mystery of Black Hills Forest.
If I could compare to anything, I'd say it
really has the feeling of an escape room.
It's very hands on, and it makes you a character
in the story.
There are certain parts where you make a revelation,
that's genuinely just creepy and unsettling.
Right now, just for Things You Missed viewers
you can go to Hunt a Killer dot com slash
CZsWorld and use code: CZsWorld, for 20% off
your first box.
Again, make sure to use code: CZsWorld for
a 20% discount and to show your support for
the show.
Can you survive the curse of The Blair Witch?
There’s a running theme of luck and chance
in Final Destination 2.
The dice hanging from Rory’s mirror, represent
chance.
The police chief considers each of the survivors
to very lucky, especially Evan Lewis, who
won the lottery the previous day.
Ironically his last words are, “**** I’m
lucky,” before getting crushed by a falling
ladder.
Walking under a ladder is considered back
luck, and so are black cats.
During Evan’s incident he tries cooking
lunch for himself using Black Cat Cooking Oil.
And Evan's new ring is a horseshoe ring,
which is considered to be a lucky charm.
Also, that's the only reason the Colts won the Super Bowl in 2007.
The number 13 is considered to be the unlucky
number and it can be seen on Eugene’s billiard
ball keychain.
This ball starts a chain reaction that nearly
gets someone killed.
When we first see this ball on his keychain,
Eugene is also 13th accident survivor on Death's list.
Officer Burke is a policeman who is part of
unit 13.
“This is Unit 13 requesting medical assistance
…”
"Let's go practice medicine."
The first individual accident scene in the
movie is Mr. Lucky himself, Evan Lewis.
We see him after he’s just used some of
his lotto money to buy expensive stuff.
In the hallway outside of his apartment, there
are a number of signs: a pile-up of toy cars
and vehicles was probably his first sign about
the incident on Route 23.
He nearly steps on a toy ambulance that says
Mt. Pleasant on the side, which is identical
to the ambulance that picks him up after his
accident.
He nearly falls after stepping on this one
eyed baby doll, which isn’t a Toy Story
reference, it’s an omen about Evan’s eventual
fate, where the fire escape ladder punctures
his right eye.
There’s another clue about that in his kitchen,
where the refrigerator magnets seem to spell
out “HEYE”, but the H falls away, (think
of a ladder as a bunch of H’s stacked on
top of one another) and the result is the
word EYE, which is what get poked out when
that ladder falls.
And the new computer he buys is an iMac.
Not a nose-Mac.
Not a chin-Mac.
An iMac.
The song he puts on is called Vitamin by the
band Incubus who are named after the Latin-derived
word Incubus, which refers to a male-demon,
another one of the demonic references I mentioned
earlier.
It goes along well with his demon-tail necklace.
He also has this monkey-demon statue sitting
by his window, which is next to a miniature
version of his 1979 Pontiac Trans Am, which you may remember
had a Phoenix decal on its hood.
He also has the firebird image on his front
door.
These are all signs that he’s going to start
a fire in the apartment, which ultimately
leads him to his death.
The mozzarella sticks he cooks are from a
company called “Surefire Snacks,” which
sure-enough is the catalyst of that apartment
fire.
I would also say that this Incubus song is
fire, but they wouldn’t have called it that
back then, so I won’t count that one.
I’m just surprised they didn’t use “Pardon
Me.”
“A decade ago. I never thought I would be
At twenty-three, on the verge of
Spontaneous combustion, woe is me.”
After Evan’s over-the-top ending to depth
perception, Officer Burke looks up more info
on Flight 180 and comes across a website about
plane crash survivors, which has photos of
each of the survivors, and for some reason
the photo of Tod is captioned as “A nice
shot before the coroner arrived.”
What is nice about that?
It’s a dead 17 year old.
Also, I noticed that their supposed “high
school photos” are almost definitely taken
from the photoshoot for Final Destination
1’s poster and just given a different background.
Various characters learn the news of Evan’s
death, including Kat, who is smoking on the
treadmill?
What is the point of that?
That would be like if I made a video but didn’t
upload it.
But there is an interesting painting near
Eugene’s TV of what seems to be a person
with their legs severed from the rest of their
body, a hint about Rory, who later gets his
legs cut off by the wire fence.
The child, Tim, is reading Stephen King’s
Bag of Bones before bed -- which is novel about
a writer who has disturbing dreams and visions,
much like Kimberly does in this movie.
Speaking of Kimberly, she has a few interesting
items of her own that I haven’t mentioned
yet, because they’re connections to things
outside of this movie.
For example, one of the first things we see
in her room is a puppet, which I think was
a reference a cut line from Mr.
Bludworth that can only be seen in the deleted
scenes.
“But be warned, to disrupt the grand design
is to unravel the tapestry of the universe.
And when you pull those threads apart, you
might find yourself hanging from them.”
I also noticed a picture of a bridge in her
room, which of course makes me think about
the opening disaster in Final Destination
5, even if it wasn’t an intentional reference
at the time.
There’s also a clown on a trapeze in her
room.
Makes me think of another scene from the fifth
one.
There’s another link to a later movie in
the franchise when Nora takes her son to the
dentist’s office and a fish gets stuck in
the filter.
We see a very similar accident happen in the
fourth movie.
Before that happens though, Kimberly goes
talk to the only remaining Flight 180 survivor,
Clear.
There’s a lot more info here about what
happened to Clear in between Final Destination
1 and Final Destination 2, so I did a whole
video on it, which you can check out right
here if you’re interested.
There are also some names written on the side
here.
The first three are Flight 180 victims, who
if you’ve seen my episode on the first movie,
you know are named after crew members.
The other two names aren’t credits, but
they appear to be other Hollywood connections,
for example, this guy worked on The Butterfly
Effect which is written by the same guy who
did Final Destination 2 so I think these could
have been other Flight 180 victims whose names
were just off-screen here.
One headline that caught my attention was
this one: Hollywood Jumps on Flight 180 Bandwagon.
So does that mean the movie Final Destination
also exists within the universe of Final Destination?
Is that what they’re saying here?
After talking to Clear and seeing some birds
in a window reflection, Kimberly makes this
conclusion:
“If Clear’s right about the order then
Nora and Tim are gonna be attacked by pigeons.”
OK, that’s a pretty big jump to make, but
whatever.
But that leads us to the next disaster scene,
which starts when we see a skull in the fish
tank -- the first clue that someone is going
to die here.
The next clue can not be seen, but only heard.
The music playing in the waiting room is a
MIDI cover of John Denver’s Rocky Mountain,
the song that showed up over and over before
each disaster in the first movie.
I’m gonna crack up the volume and roll it.
🎵 Rocky Mountain High (cover) 🎵
In the dentist’s office there are tanks
of nitrous oxide and oxygen used for laughing
gas.
This could be seen as a foreshadowing of the
explosive oxygen tanks that kill Clear and
Eugene at the end of the movie.
The way Tim dies really doesn’t make any sense
to me, like he sees it but doesn’t try to
move?
No one would have that reaction if they see
something falling on them.
But Tim’s death, as ridiculous as it may
seem, is nowhere near as outlandish as his
mother’s.
Death would arrive for her, not long after.
Here are a couple more things I love about
Hunt a Killer's Blair Witch box.
The lore.
This isn't just a generic game of Clue with
a Blair Witch logo slapped on it.
They actually partnered with the studio Lionsgate
to make something that fits into the Blair
Witch universe.
Everything they send you feels like it belongs
in a Blair Witch movie.
So everything feels very immersive.
If you love Things You Missed, you'll love
looking out for those little clues, it's a
great feeling whenever you unlock a new discovery.
The flexibility.
There are so many different ways you can play.
I had a fun time with it just playing by myself,
but there are so many clues and materials,
you could easily team up with a partner or
roommate, or even get a small group together
for a little teamthink sesh over video chat.
Unlike most ARGs, you're not just staring
at a screen the whole time, so it’s kind
of perfect for someone like me who has a job
where you’re staring at a screen 16 hours
a day.
You're gonna be getting a 20% discount using
my link, which you can find in the description.
That's Hunt a Killer dot com slash CZsWorld
and use code: CZsWorld for 20% off.
In my previous episode, I mentioned how a
lot of Final Destination characters are named
after great classic horror filmmakers, and
Final Destination 2 is no exception.
Kimberly Corman and her dad, Mr. Corman, are
named after Roger Corman; Evan Lewis is named
after Herschel Gordon Lewis and Nora and Tim
Carpenter are named after John Carpenter.
Tim’s dentist is named Dr. Lees, which could
be in honor of Christopher Lee, one of the
most iconic actors to play Dracula, and on
Burke’s computer screen, you can spot an
incident report on Barker Avenue, possibly
a nod to Clive Barker.
After the construction crew discovers little
Timmy isn’t a load bearing wall, Clear joins
back up with Kimberly and Burke to take them
to William Bludworth to try and get some answers.
Wait, look at this, is Bludworth an Apostasy
fan?
*SCREAM*
Good for him! I always though he was kind of metal.
Clear’s alertness prevents a possible explosion
at the gas station afterwards, which would
only be a temporary dodge, because as I mentioned,
she does end up dying by explosion.
Actually, kind of a lot of people do in this movie.
It is there that they figure out Mr. Bludworth’s
cryptic clue.
CLEAR: “A brand new soul that was never
part of Death’s design.”
KIMBERLY: “It throws the whole list out
of whack and we start over with a clean slate.”
BURKE: “Seems like a bit of a reach don’t
you think?”
Yes!
Thank you!
This is where the movie completely turns into
basically a joke.
They already tried the whole pregnancy thing
where new life that was never meant to be
can force death to start over in the first
movie.
They were gonna have Clear get pregnant and
have Alex’s baby, but they showed it at
test screenings, it didn’t go over well.
“The whole baby thing they didn’t like;
it was part of the way Alex and
Clear didn’t work and they didn’t buy
the baby at the end, they thought it was goofy
and wasn’t satisfying enough.”
So why in the **** did they decide to try
it AGAIN in the second movie?
It makes no sense.
So they look back at Burke’s cop car cam
to try to find out who Isabella is, and just
to show you kind of how sloppy this movie
is, according to the camera it’s 9:12 AM
when they’re on the ramp, but when it happened
the first time it was about 8:16AM, and then
when we see it again after the premonition,
it’s 8:24AM.
And then it gets much worse at the meeting
that Burke hosts for Route 23 survivors, because
Rory just completely forgets about personal
boundaries on the elevator.
“Is that dog **** dude?”
“You got something right there…
Here, I can get it for you.”
“No, it’s OK. It's alright.”
“Just, let me do it."
Very weird, but also… did you notice the
elevator music?
It’s a little hard to tell, but there’s
an elevator music version of Rocky Mountain
High.
I’m gonna play back the exact part.
🎵 Colorado Rocky Mountain high. 🎵
🎵 Rocky Mountain High (cover) 🎵
So they have the meeting, and Eugene is just
denying the whole death curse thing, I honestly
don’t even know why he came to the meeting,
cause he just mocks them the entire time, and then he leaves.
Clear explains that they need to be looking
for signs, and the rest of them try to safe-proof
the apartment, like Alex did to Clear’s
cabin in the first movie.
Nora and Eugene get into the elevator with
this weird guy, and to this day I still don’t
understand why he’s holding this stuff,
or what it even is.
Are we supposed to understand what’s going
on here even?
“Whoa…
A man with hooks.
Hey, I think I see a man with hooks.”
What does he think they’re gonna say?
OMG, he’s right!
CLEAR: “Oh my God…
He’s right!”
No!!!
Come on!
I was kidding!
Oh…
Oh, I’m sorry, was it not already weird
enough that this guy -- who we’ve never
seen before -- is holding a bunch of limbs
with hooks on them?
Just pause it right there.
*sigh*
So they try calling Nora to warn her about
the man with hooks.
So let’s break down this phone call.
“Hello?”
“Nora!”
“Who is this?”
OK, so this establishes that she doesn’t
know who’s calling.
Rather than saying, “It’s Officer Burke”,
he just starts screaming.
“NORA!
CAN YOU HEAR ME?”
Even though she’s given no indication that
she’s having trouble hearing up to this
point.
“Officer Burke, I can’t, I can’t hear
you, what?”
Well if she can’t hear him, how does she
now know who’s calling?
And also he still hasn’t said who’s calling!
“A man with hooks is gonna kill you!”
So she just drops the phone.
Not asking what that means.
Not asking for more details, not asking for
elaboration.
And then she immediately dies.
*SCREAMS*
There’s more like Eugene running upstairs
and suddenly having a meltdown where he tries
to shoot himself, but all of the bullets are
duds, supposedly because it’s not his turn
to die.
So are we supposed to believe that he’s
just invincible until the others die?
I mean, that makes no sense.
Cause if that’s the case, keep Kat in the
padded room and send Eugene out to do the
rest of the tasks.
If they do that, they’ve essentially won.
But yeah, it seems like they do have to die
in order, because later on there’s this
part where Death knocks down a tree branch
to move Burke out of the way so he doesn't
get killed by the flying fence that kills
Rory.
So with that in mind, the plan that makes
the LEAST sense, is sending them all in a
car together, with Kat, who is next on the
list…
AS THE DRIVER.
So naturally, that’s exactly what they do.
So at this point, I’m gonna take a break,
I’m gonna calm down, and then we can hopefully
get through the rest of this movie and the
rest of the Things You Missed.
In the episode on the first Final Destination,
I pointed out how all of the disasters manufactured
by death were somehow related to water or
liquid, and that trend continues for most
of the accidents in Final Destination 2.
In the opening disaster, the Route 23 pile-up,
we can see that the ground is wet, and water
is spraying off of everyone’s tires.
Obviously that prevented the cars from braking
when they should have, which helped make the
disaster worse, but perhaps even more dangerous
than that is what goes on in Nora and Tim’s
car.
When we first see them, Tim is drumming on
the glove compartment with a couple of water
bottles, and when the pile-up occurs, one
of them falls under Nora’s brake pedal,
so she’s unable to stop her car from smashing
into what’s ahead of them.
Evan’s fatal scene doesn’t really have
any water, but I will note that things start
really going bad for him when he gets his
hand stuck in the garbage disposal in his
sink.
Tim’s accident occurs at the dentist, starting
with when the fish tank springs a leak out
onto the electrical outlet.
Nora’s death doesn’t really involve
water at all, but it is shown to be raining
during that scene.
Kat’s death is not a result of water, she’s killed
when her airbag pushes her into a sharp object,
but Rory’s death is the result of punctured
fuel tank drips into a storm drain, eventually
causing a news van to explode and launch a
barbed wire fence at him.
Then there’s Kimberly, who has this plan
at the end that she’s going to tie and be
resuscitated and she does this by driving
an ambulance into the lake.
The two that I haven’t mentioned so far
are Eugene and Clear, who both die in an explosion
that has nothing to do with water, but you
have to consider the reason they’re there
in the first place is because Isabella, the
pregnant woman, has her water break.
BURKE: “Seems like a bit of a reach don’t
you think?”
Maybe, Burke, maybe.
That water break scene just has some of the
best acting I’ve ever seen in a movie.
“My water.
It just broke.
I’m gonna have my baby.”
“No, not here, no, you… can’t do this
to me.”
“Don’t just stand there, get me to a hospital.”
“Just give me a second to think. Um.”
Wow, just incredible performance, how did
this not win best supporting actor and actress?
So realistic.
So captivating.
“Incredible job!”
OK, I don’t want to spend this whole episode
just ragging on a movie.
I do really like the concept of how all the
Route 23 people had their lives extended because
the Flight 180 survivors lived longer than
they were supposed to.
I just don’t get this part.
“Wait a minute. Who are these people?”
“The people who got off of Flight 180.”
CLEAR: “They were my friends.”
Hold up.
Hold on a second.
Let’s rewind to the first movie because
I certainly do not remember them being
your friends, Clear.
“Nobody forced you off the plane.
You said you weren’t friends with those
that were.
So Clear, why did you get off the plane?”
“Because I saw and I heard Alex.”
Like I get that she became friends with Alex
and Carter at the end of the movie, but she
can’t act like she was friends with all
of them.
And by the way, what is this picture in her
little padded room?
This never happened.
They were literally fighting with Terry and
Carter the moment before Terry died, there’s
no point where this picture could possibly
exist; why you trying to rewrite the history
of the first one?
I don’t want to be too negative.
There are actually some good scenes in this
movie.
RORY: And if I die, would you throw out all
my drugs and my paraphernalia and my porno?
Anything that’s gonna break my Mom’s heart.”
That’s actually a really heartfelt moment.
That makes me want to root for this guy to
survive and get his life together.
But unfortunately, he’s dead 1 minute and
thirty four seconds later.
Not long after we find out that the entire
objective of this movie was a lie, because
Isabella was never supposed to die in the
pile-up in the first place, and Kimberly has
another vision, and sees a new sign, an article
that says, “New Life For Drowning Victim.”
If you read the article it seems to be about
another Final Destination-like event, where
these two guys just happened to be at the
right place at the right time to save this
woman who had nearly drowned.
One of them is quoted in the article.
“I wanted to stop at the Corn Dog Shop which
is one the other side of the hospital but
Paul said, “No way!
We’re goin’ to Dumpy’s.
In two years we’ve never gone to Dumpy’s.
I don’t know how to account for why we suddenly
changed our plans.”
It sounds like maybe one of them had a vision
or saw a sign that influenced their behaviour,
just like every Final Destination opening.
And in true Final Destination fashion, these
two guys are named after new members of the
movie.
So, as I mentioned, Kimberly drives into the
lake, and is brought back by the paramedics.
“Ready, clear.”
No you got it all wrong.
Clear’s the dead one.
This is Kimberly.
The final scene is this dinner scene with
the family of the farmer whose land they crashed
on when their tires blew out.
So they run a car into this dude’s farm,
cause all kinds of havoc and trouble, nearly
get his son run over by a news van and he
responds by... trusting them with his truck
when they just met, then inviting them over
for dinner?
In any event way back towards the beginning
of this video, I mentioned all the references
to luck, chance and misfortune.
And when the farmer’s wife learns of how
her some narrowly avoided getting hit by a
van thanks to Rory’s intervention, she speaks
the final line of the movie.
“You never told me that Peter.
That was lucky.”
Click the video on the left for the next episode
of Final Destination Things You Missed.
And if you love horror, remember to subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
the deathbell for notifications and I’ll
see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.
If you want to beat death, use a facemask
and social distancing.